the big ceos in this room are wrestling
with lawmakers over potential government
oversight of the three trillion dollar
crypto industry but how successful will
they be for more analysis we're joined
by patrick campos he's the chief
strategy officer at securency that's a
dc based company that develops financial
and regulatory tool tools for the
blockchain patrick thank you so much for
being here i think you were able to just
listen in to the end of what we were
listening to in the hearing to what
extent do you feel like the lawmakers
who are asking these questions
understand crypto and how it's used you
know when these hearings happen we
always get
some fun sound bites from lawmakers who
don't necessarily have their finger on
the pulse but do you think that they do
this time around
yeah thanks it's great to be here um i
think it's a mixed bag i think that uh
there are some who really devote a lot
of time we spend some time on the hill
and talk to a number of the members and
their staff
it's surprising how many of them
actually are very well versed in a
number of these areas but it's spotty
it's certainly not across the board and
i think that um
you have varying degrees of
understanding and also some folks focus
on areas of particular interest to them
and have a you know some expertise in
that area but perhaps not in others
yeah i mean i i hear them talking about
just how big the world of crypto has
gotten and i want to throw to a big
number here because 55 of bitcoin
holders got into the game just this past
year so the industry has just really
ballooned i'm curious from your
perspective what's the goal here for the
ceos in the room what do they want
lawmakers to walk away with today
well look i think
this is they they recognize i mean this
is a kind of a powerhouse group of um
you know of players in this industry um
very high profile um and and folks who
are doing big things and i think that
they see this as an opportunity um you
know to really move this more squarely
this discussion more squarely into the
public forum um and you know i think if
you go back a couple of years um you
know i think there was a general sense
in the industry hey nothing's going to
get done on capitol hill we have to deal
with the agencies i think maybe that's
changed i think maybe what they see is
now um the best opportunity for you know
achieving um you know some degree of
movement um in this space is going to
come from capitol hill and so i think
that's a big part of
this but look this is a very very
important hearing for the industry there
are a lot of really big topics being
covered here so um i think that they
feel the um you know the gravity the
gravity of this of this movement i
should say
is your view that the big crypto stars
here want regulation they just want it
to be done correctly
so i think um
what
there is a a clear understanding in the
space that the idea that um all of this
is going to stay sort of you know in
this sort of dark unregulated um you
know realm
that's just not the reality um you know
i think that that's they recognize that
and that's a big part of what they're
doing now they certainly look at
regulation as being a double-edged sword
it it stimulates adoption on the one
hand um but done wrong you know
incorrectly it can it can really stifle
innovation and and stifle adoption of
the technology so i think the short
answer is yes but with uh with an
asterisk right we just heard one of the
lawmakers who used to work in it saying
that uh if they had thwarted dial up
back in the day and innovation with the
internet we would we would still be
working with dial up i think that's a
really astute comparison there you know
what's the worst case scenario here for
people who work in the crypto industry
like yourselves what are you hoping to
not have happen today
yeah so we you know we we actually began
life focusing on on um you know trying
to
tie compliance into this world you know
and still trying to respect privacy so
you know we we we've seen this moment
coming um i think what you know what
they don't want to see happen uh because
there's a lot of there are two sides of
this discussion and one side of it is
look at all the terrible things that can
happen um you know it sort of unreg on
these unregulated networks and that's
certainly true
um and i think that what they don't want
to see happen is one um that this
becomes a narrative that you know it's
all horror stories i think two is that
you know this leads to kind of um you
know a one-size-fits-all or even a
co-opting of the technology i mean um
you know you could say that china has
embraced the technology whole hog but
they're doing it in a way that is you
know uh you know very antithetical to
you know say western views of civil
liberty um so that's another danger
you use the technology for not the right
reasons
absolutely and what do you think is the
uh potential impact to the more casual
retail investor you know the the
coinbase fans who maybe invest you know
a thousand bucks a year in the crypto
space what what happens to them coming
out of this
i think that there's wind in their sales
i think that this is um
you know in a sense a hearing of of this
magnitude um with this lineup um you
know brings a a a real you know sense of
validation to the industry um and i
think that um you know an investor who's
paying attention to this is going to
feel hey this is real this is even more
real than i might have thought yesterday
i i also want to get your take on the
sec what do you think today's hearing
could potentially do for you know
initial coin offerings the expansion of
bitcoin etfs do you see that becoming
more and more of the norm coming out
today
well i think there was a powerful
statement made by uh by brian brooks
about hey you know why do people have to
go
to canada to do a a crypto etf um
now you know query whether um you know
the the the regular particularly the sec
whether you know chairman gensler feels
that pressure to do something um i i
suspect that what they'll feel is we
have to do something maybe we'll nibble
around the edges maybe we'll we'll go
for the low-hanging fruit um but it's
hard to see absent some you know action
from from capitol hill it's hard to see
them sort of reversing course on some of
the things that they've um that they've
said um you know again the the the
approval of the you know the crypto um
derivatives um you know that was again
nibbling around the edges it was uh hey
we've done something but it's not really
moving the needle particularly with
respect to spot markets i think we might
see more of the same
but maybe there will be increased
pressure from from congress to do a
little bit more
yeah and i know that the idea of
unbanking and the underbanked
communities comes up a lot when we talk
about crypto i believe it's five percent
of the us uh doesn't have access to
proper banking do you think that's
something that the uh crypto folks in
the room are going to be continuously
pointing to throughout the day as kind
of leverage for these lawmakers to who
are potentially on the fence with crypto
yeah look i think it's a big part of the
message um you know to to really advance
a cause they need to appeal to both
sides of the aisle
and on one side of the aisle um you know
this this issue of financial inclusion
um and banking the unbanked is huge not
not to say that it's not important on
the other side of the aisle but but what
it what is happening i think is that um
you know i think what they're able to
demonstrate is this is a a non-partisan
or a worse than bipartisan um issue we
certainly heard from danelle dixon over
at uh over at the stellar development
foundation um how central this is to um
you know their entire thesis for their
for their network so yeah i think it's a
powerful message and i think again it
goes to that you know that that aspect
of um you know reaching across both
sides of the aisle um to to promote this
this technology
as someone who's in this space patrick
what are you going to be looking for and
listening into throughout the day as an
indication of where we might go and
where lawmakers might go with crypto
regulation moving forward
so to be honest um you know the the
questions and the if we can call them
battle lines that are being you know
drawn in that room among the you know
the the the legislators who are asking
their questions um
those are sort of as expected um i i
think i think that um you know no one's
no one has really gone off script here
um even even obviously among um you know
the folks who are um you know presenting
here so i i i think it again it it may
lead to congress feeling a little bit
more empowered to do things what those
things are remains to be seen um and um
you know and and maybe you know heading
into midterms um you know may we may see
a little bit of shifting of positions um
that i anticipate might be more
favorable to crypto
but that's hard to say as well sometimes
you you you get a hardening of a
position as you as you head into those
into those elections as well so um these
two leaves are a little bit difficult to
read right now interesting you think
crypto is going to play a big role in uh
election outcomes as we head into the
midterms
well you know i think um maybe not
directly yeah but indirectly if you if
you look at what what is really being
discussed here these are huge and
momentous issues we're the very nature
of banking and payments is being
discussed here um the different manners
by the different ways by which different
regulate regulatory agencies regulate
that's on that that's being discussed
here um the geopolitical clash between
china and the us
is being discussed here the future of
the world of the us dollar is a world's
reserve currency and correspondingly us
monetary and fiscal policy that's all
being discussed here so i i think there
will be indirect impact on the discourse
and you know leading into the election
but maybe not direct yeah fair enough it
ties into everything right all right
patrick campos really appreciate you
joining us for that analysis that was
really helpful patrick is chief strategy
officer at securency thanks again for
joining us